that guy yeah jake shields then the guy
the other guy that hangs out with the
diaz brothers don't [ __ ] come at me
you guys you won't even see me anyway
but [ __ ] calm down smoke weed let's
calm down
his buddy that fought in bellator this
weekend that [ __ ] threw an illegal
headbutt did you see that's what
daniel's talking about yeah
he's the blind guy dude
this guy jake shield what is with the
people that train with
two of the best boxers in mma have the
worst boxing in mma like if you're the
diaz brothers buddy
and you're like yeah [ __ ] vegan meals
bellator i'm like what the [ __ ] why
can't you
punch at all they didn't they were just
like no dude you teach me wrestling
and they're like what about my hands i
don't know you figure that [ __ ] out
yourself
it was the worst jiu jitsu
the worst display of [ __ ]
sportsmanship i've ever seen in my life
dude is losing halfway through the fight
he's got the mount and [ __ ] headbutts
the guy
beyond the league what did they do
[ __ ] nothing
kept the fight going they were arguing
with each other rift beltram was trying
to tell him to shut up at what you
didn't see the end
no so the end they're still bitching at
each other because the dude's like haha
you lost and dears his boys
an angry little [ __ ] man he's a very
you can tell he's a means
world-class jiu-jitsu yeah world class
oh great stop okay
just cause you're world class doesn't
mean you have to be a dick no i agree we
just discussed that
but i think that's a personality thing
too look at this headbutt right
because he's like that in grappling like
just a headbutt in the man
and the ref does nothing he tried to he
he did i think he
gave him a warning or he stood him up at
one point and told him to calm down
yeah it has to be my you got to take
points away dude you can't have it i
didn't
maybe they did but at the very end he
tried belgium tried to get him to
shake hands and little angry guy walked
off and beltran went out of the cage and
grabbed him
pulled him by the hand back and was like
you guys shake
shake [ __ ] hands and then they look
he wouldn't do it
because that aj kid lost yeah and he was
super pissed and bitter about it and the
other guy was kind of a little bit happy
about it which
made aj even angrier and then at the
very end when aj was like
i'm not even talking then you could hear
the mic and he was like it's a lot
different this ain't social media of
your [ __ ] man baby and i was like wow
you just you just caught him
and beat him but seriously that dude
shouldn't even be in bellator for doing
that i highly doubt they have him back
oh really you want uh i mean i don't i
don't know how many fights he has in
there
they're bad you can't have that dude i
agree it's gonna happen
even if he was good you shouldn't no you
can't have it dude can't have that [ __ ]
so i thought why can't the diaz brothers
go look dude
i appreciate all wrestling he got three
and two
i think he got thrown into the mix
pretty hard which i do give him credit
for at least he fought
people that were good jiu jitsu
background it's not like they're going
to toss some you know [ __ ]
i always say i'm telling you i think
it's a a lot of it's genetic like some
people are just not cut out for like
like a lot of grapplers you see there's
some that have it and some that don't
like
docker as a perfect example elite level
grappler he somehow was able to
make that transition he could snap off
some points he put in the work dude
because at one point he didn't have that
and then he put it like anus and silver
and all that but you could tell he put
in
actual work and he wasn't he's
like i can think of like maybe three or
four people americans above
like uh there's the super buff insane
buff [ __ ] house
dude the baby no the white kid um
there's tone in there's uh there's no
super challenge
[ __ ] to everyone oh uh gordon gordon
ryan who's
first team he's [ __ ] insane and then
and then uh
andre galvao i mean he's he's up there
if he's so good on the ground how come
he's in the mount and he can't finish
that other guy that you don't know
i didn't see it i didn't see it i don't
know but i'm just saying he gets people
down
he does is it just like because you can
throw strikes that really nullifies
somebody yeah he's gonna
figure out the mma game and he's not
taking as much risk because he don't
want to get reversed or something i
don't know he's not even
in the fight he's not doing the den and
dillas whatever that means
who [ __ ] ding dong dingbat jesus
christ that guy's got serious brain
damage
to them it's a little bit sad though
what
he's stud on the ground very good
clinically
like the dumbest most in the clouds
[ __ ] i've ever heard talk
how so ever i could beat brock lesnar
[ __ ] i could beat mike tyson
i could be a bandage brendan sharp on
the ground any what what
million dollars right now yeah i know
that dude's doing interviews where he's
saying that about
just pick a name i know but he's ju it's
all just
ryan garcia i know million dollars
boxing or mma i know look if you've seen
the guy
he hits like a girl and i'm like dude
you're you're
insane but it's all just uh a persona
for him
for us to talk about him do you believe
that yes did you see the interview with
ariel hawani the other day
i know dylan and he's faking it it's all
fake ah
dude you know who is training one of his
main training partners
he had me i was tweeting at the guy
sometimes
shut the [ __ ] up stun you know you know
what do you mean why keep doing that
just because he [ __ ] grapples
people good uh dude i'm monster can't
box
doesn't need to barks about it a lot too
yeah i know but you know who is
one of those fake he goes look at my
pads i'm insane and then he walks up and
goes ha ha i'm gonna
because you're talking about him that's
brilliant because because his jiu-jitsu
is so he's so stupid right now yeah
and i'm on video [ __ ] because dylan's
going like this got him
see i already said i was stupid you're
tuning in so i covered my tracks but you
know
who his main training partner one of his
main training partners is conor mcgregor
exactly so yeah
that doesn't have he had to do he's
going to connor i'm saying he watched
that
and and saw how much value it has in in
being that guy and getting attention
getting what did ben askren do
wait ben askren's full of [ __ ] he just
talks [ __ ] because he knows he's a
grappler and you're going to tune in to
watch him lose what
what so they just i mean he he knew he
was going to lose him was just saying
that no he talks all that
[ __ ] he could back it up [ __ ] can't
back it up you go to the ground i refuse
to learn his name
[ __ ] you have you ever seen but ben asks
if you're talking about striking some of
the worst striking we've ever seen in
the ufc
yeah yeah yeah but he can wrestle his
[ __ ] tail off
yeah he's got really bad strength he's
striking so bad yeah he looks like he
never even it's like i don't care
and his defense says that defense of ben
askren uh in comparison to someone like
dylan danis
ben askren's actually funny ben asprin
is very funny he's sick i find both he's
done some [ __ ]
both of them are funny because i don't
take either one seriously that's true
yeah they're both it's like yeah you're
like
are you mad at [ __ ] hulk hogan when
he gives a hot take
to me it's no different than wwe like
like when they do up when they cut a
promo they say
wrestling oh hogan ain't giving a hot
take well well the bad reference but
it's like
uh i don't know jericho jericho jericho
i don't know wrestling he's the [ __ ]
man jericho gives a hot promo he's like
this is ridiculous
no he says he's gonna do what undertaker
wait who gives a [ __ ]
whoa because wrestling's [ __ ] fake
yeah but
and [ __ ] but you're gonna get
hammered just over both
i've done wrestling all right so [ __ ] it
i know it's oh it's very sore i was very
sore but [ __ ] off
i did all your [ __ ] moves in half an
hour i was very sorry [ __ ] wheel
kicks can i
see my wheel kick and then see my
[ __ ] suplex see which sport is real
yeah
he's good at two yeah yeah because it's
not [ __ ] real
[ __ ] off no but these guys they're just
they're doing these takes and people are
paying attention there's value to it
there's a valley there is because it's
interesting freaking me out man 100
percent
fake like what has he ever said do you
go dude see the last thing i just said
[ __ ] people are freaking out
uh colby commented what do you think of
him
um yeah i've heard that that's fake but
i don't believe it i think that he's
really an [ __ ]
nope great one of the best people i know
also also very funny
kobe listen oh [ __ ] off because he went
to your food truck of course he's on his
best behavior no
he's on the [ __ ] spotlight he wasn't
oh [ __ ]
dude let's just quit the gimmick we
don't need the girls here he's like dude
you know i can't do that
like i gotta run with it's like that's
that that that's all planned that's all
schtick
he's a good dude it's all dude it's
entertainment
it's entertainment fighting now i've
i've heard guys i've heard
jason you found out how the hospital is
jason i've heard
four or five people [ __ ] dick four or
five people off the air that no
have said the same thing you're suckers
you're sucked in
you're the dumb ones i'm so cool a lot
of people show that dude
sucker right now but trust me when we
get off the camera i'm gonna [ __ ] be
totally not be into [ __ ] until i'm off
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] not into a racist
horse
he's a [ __ ] idiot wait wait he's not
racist because he's a troll
he's [ __ ] make up [ __ ] too i'm going
to be super friendly when the [ __ ]
camera's off trust me
yeah do you tell people alice is
actually pleasant off the camera like i
am you've always been nice
it's not true i'm a mig
i'm a d i've talked so much [ __ ] on you
you don't even know yeah i don't care
damn it because i know you don't mean it
yeah i didn't really
trying to think of my head yeah but for
him it's all uh it's all a
shtick dude it's like come on
100 like does he do you think he's had
sexual relations with any of those girls
i doubt sexual relations
no because he came on my show and he
there were two hired girls you'll love
this
they're too hard girls and i go dude you
got to quit this because i'm not going
to go along with it he goes
i don't care do your thing man then
we'll figure out so like
so we get done with the interview you
know he's doing the whole stick and that
goes
there you go dude we got to go in the
back and eat that's where we do the
interview
he goes okay cool and the girls are back
there it's just awkward and he's like
and he's like dude what what can i do
because i'm telling you it's all
enactions
uh hey he looks at one of the girls who
hired you know
gorgeous girls this brazilian goes hey
uh babe well you
he goes but while they're filming we
come massage my shoulders like while i'm
eating she goes
[ __ ] you
and he goes all right that's cool oh
yeah
no he's just he's just thinking about
like how can i make piss so many people
off who are going to tune in but you're
saying
right after the camera's off he doesn't
talk to them
no not at all he's not sexually
interested in them is he married
i don't know is he gay no he likes
chicks but
that was a business it's a business he
was like someone's getting paid see you
in the interview was he mean to you
no no no so then how is it different
when he's on or off camera
in the interview he's saying he's mean
to his opponents and the girls are just
okay off camera is he like actually i
really like my opponent
i don't think he hates any of them i
don't
this is heartbreaking to me i don't know
i
like mma he probably hates me saying
this he's gonna deny it
all the guys are doing i'm gonna believe
him yep he's better actor than you
i believe his hatred for the world and
his opponents
[ __ ] but he's good though so he's good
and that's why i don't
he's less annoying because he's a real
guy that can back it up can't argue he's
a dylan dennis it's not
but you gotta realize dylan dance only
has what five pro
mma fights against [ __ ] i could beat
up every dude he fought
bomb fights and you didn't even stand
with them at all
shot in from like six foot away to grab
an ankle cancelled
when i mean you know what
douglas lima he's like douglas lima's
gonna give me a fight is that
fake he's saying is that a fake thing
when he says that
no i i think it's fake yeah douglas
lima's not going to fight him
because he would be murdered douglas
but it makes no sense for douglas lima
douglas like wait what
no fighting championships yeah doesn't
even know who dylan
i mean dylan does dylan downs as far as
the mma world is very famous
because you know there's a lot yeah yeah
i know kind of [ __ ]
great i know and he is he's legit i mean
like in in the world of grapp uh uh
submission grappling he's he's
okay he's gonna choke out anybody yeah i
like him
five percent more i'll take it enjoy
my job you guys did a great job you did
a great job thank you my job's done
i won't i would no longer tweet shut the
[ __ ] up
when i get off stage with the laugh
actually right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son